jetzt wird richtig dramatisch meine
damen und herren ärztlichen kommen sie
heute schon extrem seien sie zeuge
wenn oliver welke sich anlegt mit der
härtesten lobby der tabulosen lobby
deutschlands dem ja ich traue mich was
freundchen wahnsinn
ja ich traue mich wirklich was der
deutsche bahn bund ist aktuell wieder
mal auf dem kriegspfad weil die spd eine
bürgerversicherung will haben sie
bestimmt gelesen eine bürgerversicherung
in die dann auch beamte einzahlen müssen
ein horror und nein
um das gleich klarzustellen nein wir
wollen an dieser stelle keine
neiddebatte führen
deutschland braucht natürlich gut
versorgte staatsdiener loyale aber
können wir uns wirklich alle
beamtenprivilegien auf dauer auch in
zukunft leisten
das ist ja nur auf sie zukomme hier der
erste beamte schreibt schon sein
beschwerdebrief an den fernsehrat ich
habe doch noch gar nichts gesagt ach
richtig gut
wir sind doch auch gegen diese ganzen
vorurteile und und die ganzen uralten
beamten klischees nun dümer beamte genau
da sind wir auch dagegen das ist alles
quatsch
auch die gassen foul wird zwar alles
blödsinn tatsache ist aber tatsache ist
wirklich wir als land steuern auf ein
problem zu ende 2016 beliefen sich die
zu erwartenden kosten für pensionen und
beihilfen und zwar nur für bundesbeamte
auf insgesamt 647 milliarden euro
647 milliarden dafür hat der bund bis
jetzt rücklagen gebildet in höhe von 14
milliarden für normale angestellte wurde
das rentenniveau in den letzten jahren
brutal abgesenkt wissen sie dass pension
niveau ist praktisch unangetastet das
entspricht der garantie des dienstherren
die die attraktivität des öffentlichen
dienstes und seines veranstalters auch
ausmacht dass man im alter seinen
lebensstandard fortsetzen kann und zwar
mit einer gesamtversorgung ja aber wäre
es nicht schön wenn alle sondern
gesamtversorgung hätten wenn der normale
arbeitnehmer müsste im schnitt ist kein
witz 120 jahre lang arbeiten um die
pension eines button zu erreichen das
kann man schaffen oder ich würde das
kann man schaffen